[Music]
stephanie is in indianapolis hi
stephanie how are you
hi dave how are you better than i
deserve what's up
okay so long story short i'm 23 years
old
before i graduated high school i was
gifted about 40
000 from my grandfather to pay for
college
i received a full-ride academic
scholarship so i didn't end up needing
that money
um so it's still sitting in my bank
account
the problem is that because i was in
high school my dad was also
in this bank account it was a checking
account that both of us had access to
and it still is that way and he called
me today
and said that he took 20 000 out of that
account
to as a loan that he's going to pay me
back for his business
um he's done this before it took a long
time for him to pay me back the first
time i had to continuously ask him for
the money back and eventually he paid me
back
so i just don't really know what to
do at this point i know it's wrong and i
i want to have a conversation with him
but i just don't even know what to say i
love my dad so much
i'm so grateful he's done a lot for me
but stephanie how do you
know what to do 20 20 23. take your dad
off that count
yeah and i plan to today no there's no
planning
when you get off the phone yeah
okay move the money into an account that
is in your name only
when you get off the phone okay
yeah sweetie i know you love your daddy
yeah but he just stole 20 000
from you borrow something with
permission when you take it without
permission it's called a thief
yes i know
so now so you i want to what i'm trying
to say
very loudly is that these feelings you
have inside of you you
are not crazy
what you're you're already feeling that
weren't you
yeah a level of anger a level of
betrayal a level of disappointment
yeah yeah so the first thing you do when
you get off the phone is you move the
rest of this money
you may never see the other money again
and then i would call your dad up and i
would say dad
i love you so much and you cannot
imagine
how hurt i am and how you have broken my
heart
because i've admired you for so long and
for you to just
take money without even asking
that is not yours it just breaks my
heart because it makes me think of you
as a thief and i can't it's just hard
for me to do that
so i need you to put that money back
today dad
you don't need to use it you don't need
to use it in your business it's not your
money it's my money and you need to put
it back in my account today
and that's the right thing to do dad
yeah
and i asked him when he would pay it
back and he said he didn't know but he
would get to it
yeah no you call him back and tell him
put it back in there now because he took
it out today he hadn't had time to spend
it yeah
tell him put it back in there now right
now yeah right now and stephanie he may
try even pulled his parent card
i'm your father i did this for you for
18 years no you do not feel guilty
you be firm respectful but firm
that's my money it was given to me so i
moved everything else
and you doing this without permission
makes me
so disappointed in you you are not
you're apparently not the man i know
you're not the man i think of as a hero
a hero would never do this
i want you to shame him yeah yeah
oh that would be hard well i mean it's
it's twenty thousand dollars and it's
the right thing to do
because this guy's out of line and
somebody needs to tell him the truth
yeah it wasn't hard for him to hurt your
feelings
no so don't be hard to tell him the
truth
yeah i mean you don't have to be yelling
and you don't have to be cussing or
belligerent
just say you know i looked up to you as
a hero i love you so much and this just
breaks my heart
because i feel like you just stole money
from me without my permission
you just took money that was not yours
and didn't even ask
i can't imagine a hero doing that and i
always thought of you as a hero
and i dad i really need you to do the
right thing and i need you to put this
money back in this account tonight
you haven't had time to spend it and i
need you to put it back in there tonight
it is not your money
okay and i'll give you a chance okay
here i'll give you here's
here's your odds 10 chance he does it
90 chance he doesn't yeah
so you need to prepare your heart for
the disappointment
yeah and you may never see the 20 000
again and you'll go on with your life
but you will not allow your father to
have access to funds of yours ever again
the rest of your life
no matter what he does whether he puts
the money back or whether he doesn't
okay and on top of that stephanie be
prepared that he may not talk to you for
a little while
but that's fine yeah he'll be back
that's your father
yeah i'm so sorry
you sh you should not have to carry this
burden at your age you should not have a
father that does this to you
it's just wrong yeah it makes me angry
it's morally wrong it's ethically
wrong no parent should do that to their
own child
you need to feel that and hear that okay
yeah you don't deserve this you should
not be put in this situation at 23 years
old
to have to deal with a boundary issue of
this level
it's just not right it's wrong and um
so i hope that you can get a get his
attention and but just your
the disappointment he hears in your
voice and you need to let him hear it
it motivates him to put the money back
tonight but and don't you wait a day
because in a day he will have spent it
yeah you move the money out of this
account the rest of it
immediately in the next 10 minutes and
then you call him as soon as that is
done
don't call him until you move the money
because i don't want him getting the
rest of it
and then as soon as he puts the money
back if he does then you move that out
and you close that account
and you put nothing else in that account
ever because it's got his name on it